This next chapter that we are going to
start this morning in sha Allah is very
important chapter
that very strongly connects to the
previous chapter and very strongly
bridges the chapters to come.
We're talking about the types of najasa,
the various types of filth.
And we've established
a definition for
a najis, right?
And we mentioned that that is something
that
is not necessarily just unclean, but
that's something that is specifically
been pointed out
by Allah and his messenger as being
something that must be
worked on to remove prior to making
salat. That this is something that is
najis. It has to do with person's
prayer.
And
the chapter that we are going into today
now is the chapter regarding kayfiyat
taharat najasat.
How
each of these types of filth
is to be
purified, is to be cleaned.
There are two very important points here
that need to be understood
as kind of a
as kind of an introduction to this
chapter, to understanding this chapter
properly.
The first
is that purifying
and purity
is relative.
What does that mean it's relative?
Meaning
the floor
Does it need to be Do we expect the same
level of cleanliness for the floor that
we do for the counter?
Do we have the same level of cleanliness
that we do for the counter
and our plates that we put our food on
directly onto?
There's a different level of
cleanliness, right? So if I say
the floor is clean
that is clean with respect to it being a
floor. In that context the floor is
clean.
If that were
the counter, it may be very unclean for
a counter, but it's clean for a floor.
And if I were to say the counter is
clean,
that is in the context of it being a
counter.
It may not have the same standards as
cleanliness for a plate or a dish.
Correct?
So, what does this mean? This means that
it is contextual. This means that it is
relative.
It is relative to what it is.
This is an important point.
Because we do not have the same level of
stringent cleanliness for every single
thing.
We don't. If we did, this would be
you know, very strenuous to live like
this. And remember the
original principle that Allah founded
all of his laws
in this legislation of Islam upon, and
that is
[Arabic recitation]
That Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has not
placed upon us
in our religion
any type of
unreasonable
hardship or unreasonable
abnormal
difficulty.
Okay?
Now,
this issue of things being relative,
I do not have the same level
of
stringent
conditions
for the cleanliness of a floor that I do
for my clothing, for instance.
That I do from this type of najasa or
that type of of
Correct?
That I do for
my shoes, that I do for I don't even
have the same level of stringent
regulations for the cleanliness of my
clothing,
the bottom of the clothing or the tail
in the back of the clothing, and the
clothing up towards the upper part of my
body. Even that is contextual.
We understand that?
So, this is a very important point.
So, for instance, how does this come
into play?
So, for instance,
one of the things that we'll learn
is that the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam said to the companions that
when they come to the masjid, before
they walk in,
the person is to
look at the bottom bottoms of his soles,
soles of his shoes.
Right?
He said,
"And if you see
any kind of qadar there, any kind of,
you know,
feces or something that may have been
walked into on your way to the masjid,
then he is to
rub it into the sand and then make
salat.
Now, notice,
is there any water involved in this
process?
No water involved.
Right?
So, a person, how does this work? The
The companions, all of the Muslimin,
prayed in their shoes.
Not praying in their shoes, this is
something that came way later, hundreds
of years after the companions
radiyallahu anhu.
Everyone prayed in their shoes. There
was no standardization of carpet in
masajid. This is something that happened
before the companions.
After the three major generations, the
the companions, tabi'in, and tabi'
tabi'in.
Otherwise, it was
the norm that a person pray in his shoes
in the masjid. So,
they would come to the masjid, they
would look at the bottom of their
soles.
If they see anything there,
what kind of
waste is going to stick to the bottom
of a person's shoes?
Is it
dry or is it wet?
It's wet, right? Okay. So, he says, "And
if you see something there,
then you are to rub it in the dirt." He
didn't even say to take your shoes off.
Okay?
Just rub it in the dirt,
right?
And then,
now,
we're not even He didn't even command
the companions to examine it closely.
You're examining it from down here, from
up here, right?
So, how much is going to be removed from
that? Is it going to be removed from at
the molecular level?
Huh? If we took it to a laboratory
and we tested it,
we had a chemist test it,
with his tubes, and is he going to
find it absent of najasa? Of course,
not, right?
Now, remember,
that's that's on a person's shoes.
Now, remember, the the prophet
peace be upon him in another narration,
he said to the
women,
he said to the Muslim mean,
he said the believers
clothing
should reach to the middle of his shin.
And in another narration,
one handspan above the ankles.
The women said, "If we do this, our feet
will show."
And so he said,
"Then one handspan below the ankles for
women."
Now, one handspan below the ankles,
what's going to happen
with the clothing? It's going to It's
going to drag on the ground, right?
And so the women, they asked the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam, all these
narrations are going to come.
They They asked the prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam,
"When we're walking through the streets
of Medina, the tails of our dresses
go through
pick different types of things up that
are in the streets, right? If there's
waste on the ground,
it's going to get caught up in the
clothing."
He said,
he said, "What follows of the ground
will purify what stuck to it as you were
walking."
So he did not command the women to what?
To wash their
bottoms of their
dresses every salah.
He said, "She's just to keep walking
normally, just walk.
And And just as it was scraping on
something that is some kind of waste may
have picked up what comes after of the
ground will purify it. How pure is it
going to be?
It is relative.
Right? It's relative.
It is relative. That is an acceptable
level of purity for the tail of the
dress.
That is an acceptable level of purity
for the bottoms of the shoes.
Right?
It's relative.
We saw in another narration that the
a woman asked the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam
about the menstrual blood
that comes into contact with the
clothing.
What did he say to do?
He said to scrub it
and to wring it out
and then to rinse it. Correct?
Now,
that
is a heightened level of purity
for one part of the dress
that is more pure than another part of
the dress. So, we have the tail of the
dress
is less strict level of purity
whereas the upper portion of the dress
is a what?
Is a higher level of purity.
Is that clear? So, it is relative.
And this is very important. When we see
that a man came to the masjid and he
urinated in the masjid.
The prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
told the companions
to get a bucket of water
and to pour it on the urine.
Did that remove the urine entirely,
completely, totally? No.
What did it do? It diluted it.
Is that enough
for a person's clothing, if there's
urine on it, to just pour water on it?
Or did we just learn that if there's
najasa on the clothing, it should be
scrubbed and then ringed out and then
rinsed?
That is for clothing.
But for the ground,
that is clean for the ground.
But that's not clean for the clothing.
And so,
the cleanliness and the level of clean,
what is considered to be clean
and acceptable is relative to
what it is. The ground has a different
level of cleanliness. The shoes have a
different level of cleanliness.
The bottom, the tail of the dress has a
The rest of the dress has a different
level of cleanliness.
The
skin and the body has a different level
of cleanliness.
Understood?
So, each
thing that is purified is relative to
what it is and what type of najasa it
is.
That's the first thing.
The second thing and what we will end
with
today,
and that is that
the correct opinion
from amongst the scholars
is that
[Silence]
the scholars tell us that removing
filth,
purifying your clothing or body or place
of salah from filth,
it does not need an individualized
intention
an act of worship does. If I were
to go and make wudu,
let's say someone came and said, "Teach
me how to make wudu."
And I don't have wudu. I say, "Come with
me."
And then we turn the water on and I make
wudu, but I don't have the intention of
making salah.
My intention is just to teach him how to
make wudu.
And then as we finish, the adhan is
called and it's time for salah.
Do I need to make wudu again or
is that wudu enough?
Think Think about the answer.
I have to make wudu again. Why?
I didn't have an intention to make wudu.
I had an intention to show him.
Right? So, I need a specific intention.
Understood?
But let's say there's something on my
clothing that needs to be removed.
I say, "Okay, inshallah, when I get to
the masjid, I'll remove it."
So, on my way to the masjid, it starts
raining outside.
And as it's raining, this thing is
cleaned from my clothing.
Did I have an intention for that to come
out of my clothing in the rain?
Huh? I didn't, right? I was just walking
to the masjid.
By happenstance, it came out of the
clothing. When I get to the masjid, I
know that there was a najasa there, but
now it's gone.
Because I was walking in the rain.
Do I have to still wash that?
Think about the answer. Do I still have
to wash the place? There's no najasa
there anymore.
Okay?
It's gone.
It went away in the rain. Do I still
have to wash that place?
Yes?
No.
I do not.
Why?
Because what I just started with, and
that is that
izalatul najasa
Okay?
Making sure that the clothing is free of
najasa, it is not a type of worship in
itself
to where it needs
a individualized
intention for it to be valid.
As long as the najasa is not there,
there is no obligation upon me. It's not
an independent type of worship.
It's conceivable that a person go
through his entire life never having to
clean any najasa.
And they will not have missed out on an
act of worship. Do we understand? So,
this issue of it does not need an
intention in order for it to be valid
means that if the najasa is removed by
any means,
it is valid.
Whether it's removed by chemicals,
whether it's removed by water, whether
it's removed by putting it out in the
sun, whether it's removed by accident,
whether it's removed on purpose,
as long as the najasa is gone,
that is enough.
Okay? So, understanding that those two
things, number one, cleanliness
is is considered contextual.
Okay? Number two,
removing and najasa is not an
individualized
act of worship that needs an independent
intention.
Therefore, removing the najasa can
happen in any way that it happens.
Whether it's intentional, unintentional,
whether it's by any means,
it is considered to be acceptable.
We understand those two things? Once we
understand these two things, we'll be
able to understand the coming chapter.